[Musik]
es ist montag das ist bild live schönen
guten morgen die täter sind auf der
flucht bewaffnet und höchst gefährlich
um fünf uhr morgens ortszeit gehen die
ersten meldungen bei der polizei ein an
13 verschiedenen orten im
indianerreservat james mit cri nation
und dem dorf welden werden die ersten
opfer entdeckt gegen 7 uhr die warnung
der polizei an die bevölkerung verlassen
sie nicht ihre häuser suchen sie sichere
orte auf die polizei fahndet mit fotos
nach zwei verdächtigen mit dem gleichen
nachnamen das hier sollen sie seien
demnach soll es sich um damien um mike
anderson handeln sie sind möglicherweise
in einem schwarzen nissan rogue
unterwegs doch die fahnen und gleich der
suche der nadel in einem heuhaufen das
gebiet nämlich ist fünfmal so groß wie
deutschland
kanadas ministerpräsident gestern trio
ist schockiert in einem tweet schreibt
er ich bin schockiert und am boden
zerstört über die schrecklichen
anschläge heute hier sehen wir den tweet
als kanadier trauern wir mit allen die
von dieser tragischen gewalt betroffen
sind und mit den menschen in
saskatchewan
das motiv der täter ist bislang völlig
unklar laut polizei haben die täter ihre
opfer wohl zufällig ausgewählt
[Musik]